today we're gonna play Lego worlds it's
like Minecraft and you bros always say I
wish you would play Minecraft but I
always say I'm too hipster for that
hey I am just placing Brock Lego blocks
randomly because that's my life I also
notice that if you punch flowers in this
game you get coins punch those flowers
baby the is that an eagle sponsor
eagle what are you doing here can I use
sponsor Eagle fly sponsor eagle blah
there we can finally be together alone
Spencer eco you know I love you right
kiss me sponsor eagle ah I thought you
loved me
we have to land on him nevermind an
airplane Oh power punch it oh my god oh
it's a wild wild west look at that face
you look like
my next mistake let's add let's finish
this episode off by flying into the lava
yes just what I wanted in life sweet
death